un président ne devrais pas dire ça tout
est dit dans le titre et ce livre a
suscité en effet beaucoup
d'incompréhension beaucoup de
mécontentement qui devrait la fermer
dans le journal sud ouest alain rousset
affirme qu'il ne parlait pas du
président de la république mais de
michel sapin son ministre de l'économie
c'est lui notamment qui s'exprime
régulièrement là dessus depuis cinq ans
devrait la fermer
il nous a pas aidés il a un boulot à
faire mais à un moment donné et les
français ressentent autre chose
la preuve de son embarras ce soir avec
ce communiqué il change de version
finalement ne parle plus de michel sapin
mais deux responsables politiques
le new york times le célèbrissime
journal sérieux journal new yorkais
qu'elle lui dans le monde entier nous
dit que françois hollande est un
président quelque peu mort et à
l'étranger au lieu de nous répéter qu'il
a bien fait bien fait et bien fait il
ferait mieux de prendre conscience de ce
qui ne va pas et de ne pas se
représenter
jean ferrier culturel pour le chef de
l'état françois hollande est à lons plus
exactement au louvre lens il a inauguré
ce matin une nouvelle exposition
intitulée l'histoire commence en
mésopotamie
j'en remercie encore les élus qui sont
ici et bien sûr les services de l'état
et madame la préfète pour évacuer calais
et faire en sorte que le pays tout
entier puisse prendre ce pas ce qu'il a
fait ce qu'il a fait dans des conditions
dignes
chaque mardi à 18 heures alain juppé
réunis à son qg les parlementaires qui
le soutiennent il était au départ une
petite quinzaine y sont ce soir plus de
et parmi eux certains viennent tout
juste
de leurs alliés prénom de valérie
pécresse qui allie alain juppé avant
même le deuxième tour de la primaire de
la droite et du centre laquelle on le
rappelle vous ne participez pas que
comme l'ancien sarkozyste frédéric le
cam était détrempée malicieux regarder
des désordres du monde d'hier c'est un
événement d'une portée considérable
il reste alain juppé il reste que taqa
de l'autorité naturelle
c'est quelqu'un auquel on fait répéter
deux fois les choses un mandat pour agir
là il faut tout lire mes attentes et
c'est dommage c'est qu'il reste rohff
pourquoi parce que regarder le cadre
noir comme ça on dirait un avis
funéraire un avis de décès ces sinistres
donald trump pros passent devant hillary
clinton selon un sondage pour la chaîne
msnbc
un rebondissement ils entendent
inattendue alors que la démocrate est
visé par un nouveau scandale wikileaks
révèle en effet que la candidate
démocrate a été prévenue à l'avancé des
questions posées lors d'un débat de la
primaire démocrate
comment peut-elle être encore candidate
imaginez si ça avait été moi qui avais
fait ça qu'est ce qui me serait arrivé
la chaise électrique